I usually am a big goal maker and I  think this year it's just to let it just  be in the moment laura dern is making  good on her 2017 gold because how's this  for a moment the big little live star  was snapped packing on some serious PDA  with her new man NBA star Baron Davis  the two were snapped outside the Beverly  Hills hotel last week where the 50 year  old actress and 38 year old basketball  player literally couldn't keep their  hands off each other crazy amazing Laura  was previously married to musician Ben  Harper they were together for eight  years before divorcing in 2013 meanwhile  Barron separated from his wife Isabella  Brewster in June after three years of  marriage let it ride see what happens  see what the universe brings we'll be  keeping an eye on these two  [Music]  you